good morning John today I want to talk a
little bit about VidCon I apologize to
all the people who cannot be there the
good news is that we will be streaming
the event live on the Internet so you
will be able to be there virtually if
you were not able to be there in person
so a lot of people have been saying to
me Hank what the Frick it says July 9th
to 11th but you only have programming
scheduled for two days well we've been a
little bit quiet about it because we
weren't quite sure how to logistically
do this but what we wanted to do with
the 11th with that Sunday is have it be
user generated conference content we
wanted everybody to get to the
conference and say okay we've done these
first two days let's figure out what
we're gonna do with Sunday we've got a
convention space we've got audio-visual
supplies we maybe even will have a
little bit of a budget for doing cool
stuff and most importantly we've got a
huge collection of people who are
extremely dedicated to the online video
community what are we gonna do with all
of these things but as time progressed
we realized that it would probably be
better if we gave a little bit of lead
time and had a little bit of prep for
these things and didn't just decide
right there on the spot what we were
gonna do so that is what I'm doing today
I'm asking you what do you want to do it
could be a VidCon slash YouTube open mic
session poetry slam do they do poetry
slams anymore is that lame my good
friend and YouTube songwriter Molly
Lewis said Hank we need to set up a room
just for Calvin ball Calvin ball of
course being born of the mind of Calvin
of Calvin and Hobbes is a game that
involves balls that has no rules which
to me sounds like a pretty freakin good
time anybody for flash mobs or or maybe
the world's largest circle of people
videotaping each other everyone with
cameras maybe one of those what do you
want to do with that time because we
have got that hotel we've got it all
rented up and paid for now what do you
want to do with it because this is a
YouTube thing after all please go to
these this version of this video that's
at youtube.com slash VidCon and leave
your ideas as a response to that video
if you leave your response on this video
at the vlogbrothers channel it won't get
entered so use the VidCon version of
this video and ask people to like the
video if they like the idea and the
ideas that get the most likes will be
the most likely to be in
I'd say the most likely to be
implemented because some of the videos
might have impractical ideas like 45
minutes of Shane Dawson stroking just
stroke just touching his hair
Shane's hair Shane Dawson stroking
probably not gonna make the cut but
innovative ideas of what to do with the
people in the space that we have will
certainly be accepted I'm very excited
to see what the community has to say
about this the second question is will
VidCon be providing food for folks the
answer to that is no we will not be
providing food there will be food for
sale and expensively around sandwiches
and there's a Starbucks in the lobby
that kind of stuff but unfortunately
full economic disclosure here having a
conference at a hotel means that the
hotel is serving the food B prices are
outrageous so that was never even an
option for us unless we were going to
charge people like $400 to be at VidCon
which seems like an awfully bad idea and
the last question is is it really $35 to
park at VidCon and the answer that is
also no we have no negotiating with the
hotel VidCon attendees get parking for
$12 a day instead of $35 a day which is
still seems ridiculously expensive to me
but I guess it's better than 35
hopefully I've answered all of your
questions I can't wait to see people's
ideas for what to do with Sunday July
the 11th thank you all this is Hank
green I hope that I will see you at
VidCon